hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game that took place some uh
well 62 years ago it's a game between
Robert James Fisher and Cesar Munoz
vicuna a lot of you guys have requested
it which I thought was very weird
because uh we usually you guys request
either modern games or sometimes uh you
do request the older games but here a
lot of you requested that this
particular game and then I realized why
a article was published uh regarding
this game which I will link in the
description below if you guys want to
check it out it will be in the for the
first thing you see in the description
but it features a game uh from the
um uh from the Leipzig Olympia that was
played in 1960 uh it was the United
States versus Ecuador and um here on
world one uh truly a miracle happens and
now for those of you who are not really
you know great with chess years uh how
strong was Bobby Fischer in 1960 well he
was he was fairly strong he just
finished the 1959 candidates tournament
uh and uh well I mean you guys know uh
players that he faced there and uh
basically he is a monster now uh so you
know whoever he faces uh he he will feel
the full extent of his rat especially
with the white pieces uh but here we
don't have all that many games from
Cesar Munoz vikuna uh he is a he is a
master for example here you can see uh
there is this nice photo it says Fisher
International grossmeister that is
international Grandmaster and uh
so he is a master but uh I I imagine
there are there are uh uh games that he
played somewhere but uh in international
played there are only two events that he
has played the under-26 uh World
Championship where he defeated some
incredible names like Friedrich olafson
and um uh he feels really olafson and um
even Ben Larson uh and that's it that
was played in 1957 and now this is the
second event he's playing in uh in
international wise uh the 1960 Leipzig
Olympiad so let's uh check it out and
see why this game is so wonderful uh all
of you heard the story uh they asked
Bobby Fisher what do you think about the
dragon Sicilian and Fisher says oh yeah
you just push h4g for H5 G5 and white
wins so that's kind of exactly what
happened here uh
plays the dragon Sicilian against Bobby
Fischer and Bobby just plays all the top
engine moves but still uh he somehow
loses so what happened here actually and
why was this game uh when this game uh I
will tell you when this game was
published the next day in the Ecuadorian
newspapers they titled it uh Ecuadorian
defeated a hostile alien force that had
an IQ greater than Albert Einstein so
there you have it uh now let's check out
the game and see what is uh what is so
incredible here so Fisher opens with E4
as he usually does and uh vikuna opens
with C5 the Cillian defense is on the
board Knight of 3d6 with D4 C characters
Knight captures and now Knight to F6 we
have Knight to C3 and now while you
could play the neither Sicilian which is
the most popular today G6 the dragon
Sicilian or the dragon variation of the
Sicilian is what uh
against Bobby Fischer here and okay now
Bobby has a chance to prove uh what he
said uh he said Bishop E3 F3 Queen D2 G4
H4 you start pushing the pawns and black
resigns so let's see how this works out
Bishop to E3 and okay Bishop to G7 we
have Pawn to F3 uh castles and queen to
D2 Bobby uh prepares the castle Queen
side uh and he won many a game using
this exact uh same technique uh Knight
the C6 and now Bishop to C4 the uh the
the Fisher's weapon I I remember when I
only started learning about Chess I
learned that uh Bobby really really
liked the the light Square Bishop so
whenever I had a position and I I knew
that Bobby Fischer had this exact same
position that I'm playing uh it just
felt like you know a moment of pure like
happiness and Calamity it was I mean it
was really awesome uh but yeah okay uh
Bishop to C4 and now Pawn the A6 and
this this is the first move that really
deviates from the modern knowledge of
Chess here Bishop to D7 or Knight to D7
or the immediate capture on D4 are the
standard moves but okay yeah this was
played 62 years ago so Ponte A6 and now
Fisher plays Bishop back to B3 this is
uh pretty much if you uh cover Fisher's
games like
um you know grab any of the book that
covers them uh you will always see
against the Sicilian Fisher going in
Bishop C4 to B3 those are moves uh you
know next to each other always uh Queen
to A5 and now we have Queen side Castles
by Bobby and already if you gave this
position with the white pieces to any
modern Grandmaster they would just crush
the player with the black pieces and so
would Bobby most likely uh on a good day
but this was not a good day for Bobby
here we have Bishop to D7 and this
position as of move 11 has never been
repeated again yeah so let's see how
Bobby continues this King to B1 always a
nice profact thick idea we have Rook 8
to C8 and now Pawn to G4 now Bobby
starts pushing his pawns uh we have
Knight the E5 now preparing Knight to C4
to attack the dark squirrel bishop and
the queen which means that uh Bobby will
have to give up his light Square Bishop
uh and here uh White can immediately see
his Advantage with knights to D5 you
just open up a discovery here if uh
if you go back then white is just better
and of course if you trade here Queen
captures then we first win upon with
check and only after the king moves do
we recapture the queen and I'll wrap
upon and we just have a better position
so uh that's one way to do it Fisher
however played Bishop to H6 uh which
again is not is not terrible it's still
very much playable and white is still
better Knight the C4 now attacking the
queen and Fisher captures it Bishop
captures Rook captures and now we have
Knight the B3 uh here uh one thing that
needs to be pointed out that uh
capturing and G7 is is just crucial for
example Bishop captures King captures
now we play Knight B3 attack the black
queen and once the black queen moves uh
then we go after the Knight attack the
Knight Knight H5 now we bring the Knight
to D5 and this is just a beautiful
beautiful position for white however uh
Fisher for some reason doesn't trade
this bishop 9 the B3 attacking the queen
and now the difference is uh black
doesn't have to move the queen black and
just play Bishop captures on H6 and
attack Fisher's Queen which would kind
of force a queen trade but luckily for
Fisher vikuna goes Queen to E5 and now
we have H4 by Bobby it's like he's
possessed with this uh idea that he just
needs to push the G and H Pawn against
the the dragon Sicilian and he will just
win the game and here we have Rook F to
C8 and again uh letting Bobby off the
hook uh a bit too easy here any modern
player would play Rook captures on C3
it's a standard move
um uh to any Sicilian player giving up
this Rook for the Knight for example
yeah if uh if Pawn characters we played
the shop characters on G4 and after the
bishops get traded off let's say F
captures Knight captures an E4 now we're
gonna capture here and it's uh just a
very very uh active position for black
for example Queen D3 we're gonna play
this with check King's gonna move now we
can capture here with check we can
capture The Rook we can play Rook to see
it we don't have to capture anything and
it's uh black has all the compensation
in the world and this is perfectly fine
but okay in the game Munoz had something
else in mind he played Rook after C8 and
now we have Bishop to F4 again uh Fisher
should trade Bishops here but for some
reason he doesn't it's like uh he he
doesn't have the light core Bishop so he
needs to have the one Bishop in the game
I don't know
uh so Queen to E6 and now Pawn to H5
staying true to what he said just
pushing those G and H pawns but now
comes upon to B5 H captures on G6 we
have F characters and G6 and now Bishop
to H6 repeating and offering a trade
once again but now Bishop to h8 and now
uh simply this doesn't work and here
it's not easy to find the move for Bobby
uh you have to try something uh probably
something like Rook to C1 or queen to D3
just some slow maneuvering moves uh but
Bobby played E5 he wanted to force
things and this is what resulted in his
downfall on this particular day so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the only move that wins the game uh
forces
while I give you a couple of seconds
and also this is a another uh photo we
have it's of a lesser quality but I
imagine it's from this position where I
asked you guys to pause the video you
can see that Bobby is staring at his
opponent will he figure out what's
happening uh you can see that he he's
laser focused on the board uh and uh
well to Bobby's horror he does find it
and hopefully you guys did as well to
all of you who found Ponte B4
congratulations as that is most often
the answer uh in chess uh so yeah B4 was
played and now there really isn't all
that much Fisher can do here uh you you
can't really move the Knight because
Rook can't present C2 so here uh e
captures and F6 was played now B captors
and C3 attacking the queen we have Queen
to H2 now preparing to move the bishop
and play Queen captures on H7 now Queen
characters on F6 uh with Bishop to G5
moving the bishop with Tempo hoping for
Queen captures Bishop so you can play
Queen captures on H7 but uh Cesar just
moves the queen back Queen F7 guards the
H7 Pawn we have Queen back to E2 by
Bobby and now C captures on V2 I also
notice that the pawn is nicely guarded
by by the bishop and h8 and here Bobby
just realizes that there is nothing
better than to try and reclaim some
material Queen captures on E7 Queen
captures with the show captors and now
unfortunately for Fisher Rook captures
on C2 Rook captures on B6 and now Bishop
to A4 and this is now a terrible threat
as the B2 Pawn is defended by the bishop
the thread is just Bishop captures on B3
and Rook to C1 and Fisher can resign so
here at Bishop to G5 official finds a
way to guard that C1 square but now Rook
to F2
uh and there really isn't a good move
for Bobby uh Bishop to E3 going after
the Rook captures an F3 and now Bishop
to D4 uh countering this uh a very
strong Bishop here Bishop captures
um on the three first eight characters
in The now Bishop captures on D4 finally
the dragon is traded off but it is much
too late you have to tame the dragon as
soon as possible against the dragon
Sicilian so Rook captures on D4 Rook
captures on B3 and now Rook to D2 now
Fisher will uh still try he he's one
Pawn against four pawns but of course he
he has to try we have Rook seat the B8
now saying okay now I guard this Pawn
there's no way you can ever capture it
now I can just push this Pawn to Victory
it really doesn't matter a last attempt
uh Rook to D7 by Bobby now comes Rook
the A3
and it was uh in this position on move
36 that Robert James Fisher resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here here okay you if you play something
weird like a rook here then maybe Fisher
can get a draw with some like real
captures on H7 but after Rook day three
it's instant resign and of course Fisher
resigned there is no defense against
Rook A1 check you're gonna lose this
rook and even if you go for Rook
captures on H7 now it's just a force the
mate in seven uh still yeah you're just
gonna bring a Queen into the game and
now whatever you do
uh just a nice quick checkmating pattern
you can even give up a rook and the
Checkmate that the white king doesn't
really matter absolutely everything is
winning here so truly uh an incredible
game by Cesar Munoz vicuna who who
really there are only 18 games in the
database that he played in international
waters uh but he defeated some
incredibly incredibly uh strong players
and he faced some very very strong
players uh so uh definitely not a good
day for Bobby Bobby was very sad some
even say uh Bobby cried after this game
uh but you know all the all the great
ones do they you know they just cry when
they lose
uh so yeah uh like I said if you guys
want to check out the entire article I
will put a link to it in the description
below you have to use translate to
English so maybe not it will maybe not
be perfect but um yeah you know it's uh
very much uh understandable uh so yeah I
really hope you guys enjoyed it uh we
always mentioned this story when you
know someone asks Fisher what he thinks
about the dragon Sicilian he's like yeah
you just push the pawns and uh White
wins but uh you know maybe like 99 times
out of 100 but not a hundred times out
of 100 it has Cesar Munoz vicuna here
has shown us uh so yeah and once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it uh I
would like to thank uh Omicron uh
Pikachus Kelly Ishmael Rivera Joshua
figure all intag and Richard Nickerson
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon continuing to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
such as this one and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day